surpris de voir que le message de logos
par ce pauvre plus fort que ça un
message économique dont on a besoin et
puis j'ai l'impression que ça passe pour
on est on est on assez déçu on est
surpris et donc qu'est ce qui risque
d'arriver contenu que la caq base selon
j'ai l'impression que le parti québécois
va réussir à rallier un peu par par la
peur les gens par rapport à la charte
par rapport au référendum qui va gagner
ce que la peur va emmener les gens parti
libéral est ce que de notre côté l'autre
peuvent amener les gens parti québécois
j'ai l'impression que ça va être une
lutte à 12
un homme fort gentil qu'on a rencontrée
ce matin à boucherville la
circonscription de montarville sur la
rive sud de montréal est vraiment sans
contredit une des circonscriptions à
suivre le soir du 7 avril
pourquoi parce que c'est une
circonscription de la cac
madame roy qui est député actuellement
de la cac
une circonscription que le parti
québécois veut vraiment avoir c'est là
que se présente simon prévost donc une
des vedettes que présenter madame marois
en début de campagne monsieur prévost
qui était à l'association des
exportateurs et manufacturiers du québec
nathalie roy de la caq j'en ai parlé
jacques gens dont c'est un pharmacien
qui pratiquaient les le dessin mais qui
est candidat libéral là-bas et jean-marc
ostiguy candidat de québec solidaire
nathalie roy avait le vent dans le
reportage a été fortement courtisé
d'ailleurs par les libéraux qui aurait
bien aimé la présenter candidat parce
qu'elle est de plus en plus aimer c'est
ce qu'on a vu ce matin dans la
circonscription qui va gagner dans
montarville dernier petite note avant de
vous présenter le reportage c'est la
circonscription québec où on a voté en
plus grand nombre
la dernière fois 88 % le taux de
participation montarville une
circonscription à séez également une des
plus aisés au canada en fête au québec
évidemment donc avec un revenu moyen de
56 mille dollars
ces bouchées rvc saint bruno en voici ce
que ça donne on a rencontré les trois
principaux candidats nathalie roy c'est
plus dur cette fois-ci zone
toute campagne menée par ailleurs la
première photo que j'ai trouvé très dur
parce que tu es la première fois de ma
vie que je me lancer en politique je
n'avais jamais fait ça donc on découvre
un monde qu'on ne connaît pas mais
effectivement c'est difficile ne
serait-ce que la température aujourd'hui
face à l'oeil on est gâtés mais c'est
quand même moins 15 ce matin c'est
difficile dans la mesure où c'est une
une campagne électorale
mais une campagne qui n'a pas d'enjeu
c'est pendant marois s'est lancé pour
une seule raison en campagne électorale
c'était pour aller chercher une majorité
c'est ça l'enjeu pour madame marois mais
c'est pas une campagne avec un enjeu qui
tient à carreau citoyens il ya plusieurs
choses qui ça va dans toutes les
directions
prenez ce référent dernières élections
sur le programme gouvernemental
j'avais besoin de le répéter souvent si
on vous le fait que ce n'est pas une
élection
c'était plus au début de la campagne lot
mais ce nom n'est jamais passé vraiment
dérangé beaucoup plus locaux mais
celui-ci vous servez des saint-bruno ces
deux endroits où les gens sont très
fiers et déjà d'un certain standing très
attachés à leur région ils vivaient de
la prospérité il va des emplois ils
veulent de plus en plus travailler sur
plaques sont de moins en moins la moria
ne les comprends ouais ça ne peut pas
être enseignant donc
milieux de vie intéressant création de
richesses d'emplois prospérité c'est en
ça que discours vice versa les
discussions que j'ai avec les gens c'est
beaucoup plus parce que à la fin ils
savent bien qu'on va avoir un
gouvernement
j'étais membre de plusieurs comités
j'étais alors des pharmaciens jcj je me
suis dit non je fais le saut nouveau a
débuté avec les clients parce que si son
amant 6 et des valeurs puis je voulais
tout simplement apporter quelque chose
au niveau
je voulais apporter ma brique dans ce
tissu social on a mieux vous cachez moi
sur pékin ben oui alors c'est pas je
trouve que madame marois de la
difficulté à faire passer son message et
les opposants en profite gaiement alors
c'est moi ça me fatigue ce sens que on
entend tout à parler de la même chose et
pas des choses importantes
vous trouvez qu'on parle trop de
référendum parce que c'est pas une
élection référendaire
je jette encore quelques pulls mais
qu'est ce qui vous fait exister que si
déterminant pour vous ah c'est sûr
toutes les chances d'aller au pouvoir de
se rendre au pouvoir c'est savoir guidé
mon choix la sage et plus qui veulent
gagner moins' alors moi danser les
libéraux de quoi les électeurs
ici je reste extrêmement surpris les
gens me parle ici des services de santé
et ont prises en plus et les cycles qui
pour moi un seul essai c'est une ligne
c'est une extension de lignes de
produits en ligne alors il faut
absolument qu'ils se fassent mais ici le
celle ci est ce que les gens me disent
c'est juste correct pour faire les prix
sont jeunes ils sont obligés de faire
sonner à varennes
ou bien ils sont obligés d'aller site à
longueuil ici il n'ya pas de clinique
médicale de gm et le groupe de médecine
familiale
alors ici il ya vraiment un besoin
urgent au niveau 6 de la santé comme par
exemple n'y a aucun pédiatrie 6 puis
boucherville depuis cinq zones où il ya
quand même beaucoup de jeunes familles
vous savez c'est quoi le problème et
servez-les et saint-bruno formant tarbes
un nouveau compter qu'en 2012 ce sont
des gens qui travaillent
forme professionnels travailleurs
autonomes entrepreneurs et belle
diversité de gens qui traversent les
ponts il près du pôle it à girac parti
pour aller à montréal pour aller
travailler la plupart d'entre eux ils
payent normes et mains de taxes et
d'impôts mais ce dont tim par madame
marois j'ai pas de service mon enfant
était mon enfant est autiste mon enfant
à l'école et à un premier blanchissage
mais même l'école les coleman les
japonais nommément de taxes et les
petits n'ont pas les services auxquels
ils ont droit les endroits est ce ça me
touche beaucoup c'est quoi votre
argumentaire là quand vous savez où pas
écouté le meilleur argumentaire ma
feuille de route
ça fait 25 ans développement économique
des lieux d'économie donc je leur
explique aussi dans les dernières années
où je travaillais de crecques les
entrepreneurs je sais comment ça ce
crâne en quoi je sers pas sa seule
maintien et on a la politique qui vient
soutenir ça et pour l'économie qu'un
élément qui émarge ans l'électrification
des transports
ici le lien vraiment un pot de
croissance en application les transports
et ça c'est 1000 à 4000 par cyber-ark
peuvent en parler parce que ce n'est pas
sur leurs écrans radar n'y croit pas et
nous on y croit on que pour la région
justement sur le sur le front économique
emploi qu'est ce que vous leur proposez
que le candidat libéral ne leur propose
pas un député
roy ne leur propose d'abord il ya
l'équipe à mon avis on a vraiment une
équipe qui est solide qui on est déjà un
marchand et une politique économique qui
était déposée l'automne dernier qui est
extrêmement bien fait d'ailleurs c'est
pas étranger au fait que je suis je suis
maintenant au parti québécois je l'aï
regardé attentivement cette politique là
j'en ai discuté avec le gouvernement
nommé dans cette fonction
vous pratiquez bien alignées donc les
gens le sentent actuellement ce qu'on a
c'est du concret une vraie politique qui
est en place pour mieux continuer à
mettre en oeuvre
nouveau cra sinon rien de concret
certainement pas la cas qu'il ya aucun
programme économique sinon de vouloir
donner une fois mais dollars à tout le
monde ça c'est pas très utiles ainsi
d'abord nos pays moyennant plus d'un
crochet n'y a pas d'usiné dollars
qu'est ce qui motive votre choix
qu'est-ce qui est le plus important pour
moi c'est un dans l'oeil aux économies
et aux également la chambre les deux
donc vous pencher vers le parti
québécois à cause la charte
oui est ce que le référendum vous ferez
n'en a pas pas du tout voir je sais que
d'après des sondages dont on n'est pas
prêt mais moi je pense qu'on perd on
perd on pas des dons dans les deux côtés
alors pour moi non si on ne le dit je
vous aime je vous ai m
neige et par un référendum nous on n'en
veut pas de référendum alors faut leur
expliquer que un vote pour la cac c'est
un vote contre un référendum les gens je
pense que il était peut-être prêts à
voter pour un gouvernement un parti
québécois mais ils sont pas prêts à les
sites au référendum le goût de le goûter
une image pour beaucoup de la marche pas
c'est que le parti québécois risque de
reparler 56 oui
bon je dirais que madame voit encore des
bonnes chances cette année même si
évidemment la caq sens - moyens en force
mais je donne l'impression que ça se
réalise et elle est appréciée
vous êtes comme comme député est-ce que
vous votre choix est fait bon jouer pour
faire encore mais ça serait une bonne
équipe au prêtre pour madame marois qui
risque de l'emporter
moi je crois que s'il est pénalement roy
s'est appréciée oui je crois
mais ce n'est pas vrai je suis ici où
est ce que votre choix est fait je crois
que oui
qu'est ce qui est déterminant dans votre
choix la loyauté surtout est-ce que vous
devez vous forcer pour ne pas regarder
les sondages pour ne pas trop lire la
campagne nationale ce qui se passe avec
votre chef et tout ça pour vous dire on
y voit coûte que coûte
je me décourage pas parce que je
travaille pour les gens je répond à
leurs questions à leurs besoins leurs
demandes
et si tous qui décideront patrick les
troupes belges mais trouve courageuse
parce fois vous ne regrettez absolument
pas votre choix d'être candidat de la
kek parce qu'on veut est courtisé et des
joueurs qui veut contrecoup physique ou
plus qu un gros pour être le nasdaq
c'est vrai oui vous regrettez pas de
quoi être non moi je suis entré en
politique pour monsieur françois legault
quand il est arrivé moi j'étais genre wi
fi des ailes je suis pas quelqu'un qui
par crainte de peut-être perdre ces
élections vont changer non moi je veux
faire de la politique autrement j'y vais
pour les idées j'aime les idées que
l'homme sur la table et je suis allé
pour les idées mon déficit évêques
partout à la fois d'ici deux semaines et
de leur dire c'est pas d'élection
référent
de le répéter c'est de le répéter c'est
quoi la priorité on le répète mais je le
répète effectivement chaque fois mais de
moins en mois j'ai besoin d'en parler
parce que je pense que ça commence
tranquillement percolé bien compris que
l'eau mais ça peut être un peut
contaminer le début de la campagne c'est
ouvrir dans un certain sens mais je
pense que ma voix était ferme au débat
on va continuer de répéter
d'après certains programmes dans les
ressources de ce qu'est ce que pour moi
dans le fond dans votre programme on est
plus sur la question référendaire uni
sur la question de la création d'un faux
de la qualité de vie dans la région
la lutte à trois je pense que les gens
vont réfléchir puis ils vont manger deux
sens sur le terrain si polarisé l'un
d'entre vous y est le parti oui oui au
niveau de la iv les gens ils m'en
parlent presque pas parce qu'il dit gens
qui on vote la quête
même si madame leroy elle est vraiment
dynamique si dans la région sont on va
être en vrai en troisième ils veulent
position retrouver cette en position que
moi je leur dis moi je leur dis moi ma
position c'est agir local penser global
moi ma job c'est de prendre si des
dossiers les assimiler discuter avec les
gens les porter à l'assemblée nationale
les rediscuter les défendent pour
revenir ici merci pour suivre avec
beaucoup d'attention
bonne fête papa merci beaucoup ça fait
plaisir